we saw Joffrey died and season four the
purple wedding what was your reaction
you really built it up I really wanted
to punch him in the face just before he
died
the latex [ __ ] I mean I think it's one
of the things for anybody that reads the
books you know from very early on you're
just sitting there going you know it
would be a very good day when Joffrey
finally gets it yes he was so utterly
horrific it wasn't it's like a Caligula
was so lovely to see him gasping for
breath in his eyes desperate reaching
for his mother looking around for help
no help to be found turning sour
disgusting it was brilliant
I mean I loved it everybody must have
been just laughing with glee
you know when they saw his eyes bulging
at his eyes had red and the froth coming
out of his mouth amazed actually because
they did a lot of stuff in post so they
kind of did it the whole thing with his
eyes and I think they made like his skin
kind of come out a bit more like purpley
and I was really like wow that's a
violent death like a silent but really
violent death you could you could see
his soul kind of go to hell that was
definitely oh my god scene that was one
of those once which I had my life hands
covering my face I wanted to be even
more bloody and more I wanted to be
really awful but it wasn't very nice but
I wanted to be worse than that I think I
rebounded and watched a second time to
be honest with you but I'm that horrible
and callous
I watched it twice as I seen I thought
it was spectacular the director cebre's
was just incredible and he had the whole
scene from start to finish in his head
at any given second he knew where the
camera had to be he knew what the actor
had to do it was just a real buzz to be
on the set for that week we filmed it
over five days information it was
boiling hot I was okay because I was in
my flowery stuff but people like Dan who
plays budget pain he was in like leather
upon Mike Armour like they're just
sweating that hit something was crazy I
was about sad failure I'm almost Jack
Jack
is one of the nicest kids you're ever
going to meet so for me I found it very
very difficult to film that scene
because I wasn't going to be working
with him again jack is actually a very
very sweet boy and very bright fairly
intelligent young man with a lot of
natural talent but then when he finally
does go you realize what a great
character was what a joy it was to watch
Jack Gleeson perform every every week so
see ya mixed bag mixed feelings I mean I
think Westeros would be a better place
but you know HBO all of these has
definitely lost this of yeah a great
character that's a major character
garden though I mean I don't accept the
same of item okay you love to hear them
Jack Gleeson is one of the loveliest
loveliest people you would ever know I'm
sure you've heard this a million times
but he plays literally one of the most
hated people on camera and watching him
die was beautiful just beautiful
it must be vital to be what about hated
men in the world I do think his
character will probably go down in
history as one of the best bad guys ever
and that's a lot of credit
Oh